hey what's up my name's Samuel Leeds and
in this video I'm gonna be explaining to
you and exposing and revealing exactly
what I personally bought and invested in
property wise in 2019 so this is the
kind of stuff that people tell me not to
put out my business mentors my property
mentors my advisers my solicitors say so
don't tell people what you bought this
year that's kind of personal you need to
keep some things to yourself well you
know what maybe it is but on this video
I'm going to tell you everything I'm
gonna tell you about the three HMOs that
I bought where I bought them and what
the figures were I'm gonna tell you
about the piece of land that I bought
which we're building six houses on from
scratch give you the figures and where
it is the to beat our our our deals buy
refurbish refinance rent where I bought
them how it's going what happened
exactly the castle renovations and
what's happening with that we spent over
half a million pounds this year on
renovating the castle I'll tell you what
what's happening and how much more money
we need to invest in the castle the
three deals that went wrong and I'll
give you the lowdown and why it went
wrong they fell outta bed it didn't
happen me giving millions of pounds to
people on bridging finance how much
interest I've expected and how that
worked and finally the move to London do
I rent or do I own my offices and where
I live and how much am I paying and one
of the figures you're gonna get to know
all that in this video but please do
smash that like button if you haven't
subscribed to the channel and turn the
notifications on please do that as well
and I'll see you at more momen hmo's 3
hate your Mo's okay I bought 2 HMOs in
Birmingham 1 hatred Doncaster there was
one in Birmingham which was a four-bed
there was one in Doncaster which was a
four-bed and the other one in Birmingham
was a six bed I don't like buying five
bed nature motors and the reason I don't
like buying five bed HMOs is because
when you get to five bedrooms you need a
license and I think if you're gonna get
a license anyway your mains will do a 6
bed 7 bed and you need planning
permission so the sweet spot is too
woven by forbid HMO and not have a
license or a six bed and have a license
but not need planning permission what
are the figures so I bought two HMOs
remember them the four bedrooms one
hundred and sixteen thousand pounds and
the six bed was one hundred and fifty
one
five hundred I put in a specific offer
and they suggest always be specific when
you're offering rental on
I'm getting about 400 pound of room you
can do the match the four beds giving me
about 1600 pound a month the six bed I'm
getting why over 2,000 pound a month on
that and they're going along really
nicely the reason I bought them in
Birmingham the reason I chose Birmingham
HMOs is because in 2020 in June article
4 is coming into the whole of Birmingham
which means that you will need planning
permission to turn a single letter into
a HMO however if you did it before June
2020
you don't need planning permission you
have automatic planning permission
because you have the grand-father rights
I will have the grandfather rights my
HMO Doncaster I bought nine to seven
thousand pounds for the property and
then they brought in October for in
Doncaster October 2019 they brought an
article for I've already got a buyer for
the house for a hundred and forty
thousand pounds oh I bought it for
ninety seven I've already got a buyer
for one hundred and forty and I've
because it's in Doncaster and I haven't
got management systems in there I passed
that one to somebody I've got a
guaranteed rent so someone's giving me a
guaranteed rent a five fifty each isn't
amazing but I don't after my bills I
don't about anything and they're gonna
be buying it for 140 as well down the
line we've fixed the price already so
I'm kind of happy HMOs are bought I
reckon I probably should have bought
some more HMOs but I'm happy with the
three that are bought so what else do I
only buy HMOs nope I also love single
net properties in fact my plan was to
buy six single at properties in 2019 I
actually have done more than that so
I've smashed my goals two of them I just
bought that needed work so I bought them
and I did I've added value and then
refinance them and pulled the money out
so I did one in Burnley and worn in
Darlington these houses are not
expensive houses there's like 60 70
thousand pound houses spend ten grand on
them lift the value up by 20 30 grand
get a new mortgage pour the money out
it's a strategy that I've been doing for
absolutely years young keys so those are
the two brr deals but more exciting than
that is I'm building from scratch six
houses so I bought a piece of land in
Lincoln that cost me three hundred
thirty thousand pounds
I'm doing this in a joint venture
because literally I'm not doing anything
I'm not doing any work I just rock up
every couple months with a yellow
hardhat have a look around the land was
sourced by my joint venture partner
it was also it's also being overseen
project managed everything's being
sorted I'm putting all of the money in
and I'm getting 66% of the profits and
I'm giving 33% approximately of the
profits so the land was 330 ground
there's six houses it's gonna cost five
hundred thousand pounds the houses the
Foundation's all done and they're being
built as we speak and that should be
expected to be finished by around March
2020 and the we've already had this is
the good news we've already had a Rick's
valuation done on the end value of the
six houses at 10.35 million which means
there'll be four hundred thousand pounds
in profit so I'm like really happy with
that deal really excited definitely
planning on doing more but that's gonna
be on another video on what's to come in
2020 you may remember last year in 2018
I bought what was that property again oh
yeah a castle last year I bought castle
that is being renovated this year in
2019 what's happened with the castle
little update I've spent half a million
pounds on the castle it doesn't look
that different nothing's happened
no-one's even picked up a paintbrush the
thing that's happened is we dealt with
Japanese knotweed we've dealt with the
rare species of bats that meant that we
couldn't do anything because there's
bats living in the property said we had
to quit you have to you have to protect
the bats right there was trees that were
everywhere there was trees they were
covering the lights that were bringing
leaky roof and stuff in because there
was so wet so what we done we've had to
have planning for everything we've had
to get the conservation officers to
agree for everything so the Japanese
knotweed is under management the bats
have all been taken care of they have a
home
you're okay bats we love you we also
have the trees the trees have all been
removed
we've got planning permission for all
what we want to do everything's been
accepted so it's going well lots and
lots of time has been spent into the
planning we've spent a half a million
just on the structure of the property
there was serious cracks there's really
serious problems but it's coming
together and 2020 August is where we're
going to expect it to have our first
show home
in the castle so what else I mean I've
been involved in 29 property
transactions or 29 property deals in
2019 haven't necessarily bought them all
myself I've also been doing something
which is basic like bridging I have been
giving people money to invest with and
I've just been asking for a guaranteed
fixed return on that so how does that
work I've actually given us seven
figures which is over 1 million pounds
so I've given that over 1 million pounds
in cash to my success students to my
peers to my colleagues to my property
homies and they've been investing and
I'm just getting a guaranteed return so
how that works is I'll ask for a minimum
of 14 percent usually with a 1% in one
person out charge and I'll have a charge
on the property so I've done a lot of
those deals and I'm gonna be continuing
doing that you have to wait for the next
video what I'm doing in the next decade
but that's been kind of caught it's
completely passive it doesn't excite me
massive laid but 14% with a 1% in 1% out
I guess he's better than a prod in the
eye with a sharp stick
I'm also moved how so I've moved house
to London we've also moved that offices
to learn them if you've been following
me you probably see that did I have to
buy to that no this house that I'm in
right now I went I pay 7,000 pounds a
month rent on this house is beautiful I
like it how much would it cost to buy I
don't really know probably a few million
pounds the offices in London we're in
Marylebone oh my goodness I love working
in London the only thing is it is so
expensive but we knew that when we moved
so we're paying 18 I think's 18 thousand
pounds a month on our office space in
London that's supposed to be up to 50
people but we're on now we have about 40
members of staff and it's getting
crammed plans to grow big time next year
so when we are looking for a new bigger
office maybe somewhere a bit more
economical but still has to be beautiful
because we need to our staff to come to
work and be like this is nice so that's
kind of what I've been up to
has it all been good know all the stuff
I've told you about is good but I didn't
tell you about some with the bad stuff
should I tell you about the bad stuff
I'll tell you about the bad stuff had
three property deals really good deals
there's probably no point me even going
into the into the details of them but
what I'll say is this they dragged on
and on and on to the point where I'm so
frustrated eight months I have my offer
accepted and after eight months of still
not completing on them I pulled out I
pulled out because I was just getting so
frustrated and it was just it was taking
it was so much mental space in my mind
and so much energy like I don't
completed you have a complete yet I
can't pick up the phone speaking to the
sister speaking to my PA what's going on
haven't we competed yet oh no we need
this oh this lender said that we can't
go ahead read a new lender oh now I need
this and I just I just got so frustrated
with it and that was when I decided to
buy the pizza land instead so I guess
the lesson in that is in property when
the balls in your court
you to act fast you need to prepare to
make real fast decisions when the ball
is not in your court you need to be so
patient because things can take a very
long time but in my opinion eight months
was just too long so for the serviced
accommodation apartments that I was
purchasing in Birmingham and Litchfield
I'm really sorry I just pulled out in
the end it was just taking too long
taken up too much mind power so I hope
you enjoyed this video there are the
figures there are the facts is all out
there what I bought in 2019
if you liked the video again please do
smash that like button also if you
haven't subscribed do that turn the
notification bell on and you can
subscribe below another thing I've been
up to in 2019 is helping other people
with their property journey I love
starting from scratch and it was
actually 2018 when I started from
scratch in property and I built up my
portfolio all over again
however this year in 2019 I helped
someone else do the same so there's a
guy called Glen and Glen have no money
no property experience he also had ill
health and I moved into his house for
seven days with a goal of helping him
become financially free if you haven't
seen that video you so have to watch it
also this year in 2019 it's not quite
the end of the news of the year yet but
so far I've helped a hundred and one
people become financially free my goal
was 108 because previous year 2018 out
54 I wanted to double it this year I've
helped 101 people become financially
free and leave their job and go
full-time a property I personally think
it's amazing and I'm really proud of
that so if you want to watch me
Glen become financially free you can do
that right here if you want to become
financially free in 2020 and you want to
come to the property investors crash
course then you can do that right here
I really were just just getting booked
on so click on this link and come to the
crash course